here's the hard truth about getting
great it takes time and dedication it
takes a willingness to accept that
you're not yet good enough it takes the
ability to stare at the places that you
know that you're weak to really look at
those things and not let it affect your
sense of self-esteem and not let it
affect your sense of self-worth so that
you can still get the momentum going but
you have to understand that in the
beginning
we're all terrible
and as henry cartier-bresson said your
first 10 000 photographs are your worst
and so the thing that really makes great
art are the people that continue to push
and the people that continue to work and
face how inadequate they are and really
understand that at the end of the day
greatness is a craft greatness is a
process greatness
is a habit
greatness is the little things that you
do every day over time going out every
day unafraid of whether or not this is
one of the ten thousand terrible things
that you're gonna do it's being unafraid
to make those mistakes is being unafraid
that you're not yet great
hey it's kevin carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that's holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some
incredible success motivation enjoy
as marianne radmaker said
courage doesn't always roar
sometimes
courage is the quiet voice at the end of
the day saying
i will try again tomorrow
and that's it
if you want to be great that's what you
have to do you've got to get up again
tomorrow you've got to be willing to
face another day you've got to be
willing to accept that you've got to get
through the bad ideas before you can get
to the good you've got to understand
that you have to start as an apprentice
you have to start as a person going and
getting t and you have to accept that
that's the job that you should be
playing that you should be working for
somebody else you should be looking up
to somebody else's seeing what they can
teach you because what you know
is that you're there to learn what you
know is that you're there to get through
the 10
000 bad photographs that you need to get
through to ultimately achieve greatness
and if you make the catastrophic error
that so
many
make
to try to tell the world extraordinary
today to try to get the world to follow
you and look up to you and think that
you're something
today
because the people that really win are
the ones that invest
today the ones that listen today the
ones that spend every ounce of their
energy amassing mastery getting better
every day working their asses off to
improve their skill set to relentlessly
look at the things that they're not
doing well to understand that they have
to break themselves down and get rid of
all of their ego before they can really
find greatness
those are the people that we remember
so if you want to be remembered
if you want to achieve real greatness
you just need to have the courage to
show up every day
and take another swing
take another photo
try another task
do something that scares you
and do those little things over and over
and over
until you win
number two eliminate bad habits with
dean graziosi welcome to the millionaire
success habits podcast where week after
week it is my absolute obsession to
anchor in the foundation the rules the
habits for success as i'm recording this
audio for some of you video for some of
you i'm standing in front of my house
it's my dream house
but it didn't come from some magical
money machine i know i always say that
it didn't come from the lotto it didn't
come from getting rich overnight it
didn't come without work and and hustle
it didn't come without massive failure
in between the successes so when i share
i'm trying to anchor in the tools that
allow you to plug anything in and be
successful today i want to talk about
something different i don't want to talk
about what you'll gain
by being successful i'd like to talk
about what you have to give up what you
have to let go of
as you take this journey to be more
successful as you gain self-education by
listening to me and others that are
actually playing the game at the highest
level possible as your mind grows as you
shift your thinking you're going to have
to let go of old thoughts you're going
to have to let go of beliefs that may
have been your parents you know
sometimes you're republican because your
parents were or you're democrat because
they were you're christian because your
parents were or you like a certain
football team because your parents like
that football team well it's the same
thing here when it comes to thinking
love your parents love your surroundings
for when you grew up and always cherish
that but if there's another level of
life that you desire and you crave you
might have to give up some of the
thinking that they gave you
you might have to give up some friends
along the journey of being an
entrepreneur i can remember being young
and family members telling me how nuts i
was and and that i should stop being a
dreamer family
they kind of get a pass and you go
through and sometimes you're close
sometimes you're not at least in my case
and then it circles back around but
they're your family they're there for
life but i can remember friends
that would always tell me slow down dude
that stuff's for other people you can't
have that and i can remember friends
literally getting mad that i was going
after stuff or investing in real estate
or investing and trying to get on tv
when i did my first infomercial or did
my first course and training on how to
help people go faster and my success
training and i remember along the way
that i would have friends ride with me
to a certain level
and then they couldn't handle anymore
because they didn't want to go for it or
they felt inferior because not that i
was successful it felt inferior or maybe
it was ego or maybe it was envy
but they would start
wanting to drag me back to them and the
truth is i had to let them go there was
nothing i can do some some stuck uh
literally recording this right now in my
house and behind me if you're watching
video over on the other side of the
house is my dearest friend from when i
was literally five six seven years old
we met
he's really one of the few friends that
stuck the whole way i still love the
guys i grew up with but a lot of times
it just changes
because i want to surround myself with
people who have a bigger future mindset
they want tomorrow to be bigger than
yesterday a lot of times in life people
get stuck without even realizing it
doesn't mean they don't have huge hearts
doesn't mean they're amazing doesn't
mean you don't love them and will love
them to a day you die to the day you die
but they have bigger past mindsets so
when you're talking about how tomorrow
could be better they're talking about
back in the good old days when we had
that other president we were back in
college back in high school back when
the economy was different back when the
republicans ran it back when the
democrats are or whatever it is they
have a bigger past mindset
and you looking at a bigger future
mindset just conflicts
and you have to let them go
there are some habits that you picked up
along the way
that served you at one point in your
life there's habits that got you out of
your first job maybe into your business
or or got you the promotion
there was habits that got you in okay
shape there was habits that allowed you
to have pretty good thinking but
remember your best thinking got you here
it's the same thing with your habits
your best habits got you here so i'm to
ask you to analyze certain habits that
you have but look at them through a new
lens they were the habits that got you
here they were the habits that got you
out of egypt are they the habits that
can really take you to the promised land
i love that i got that from dan sullivan
one of my mentors he said yes got you
out of egypt no takes you to the
promised land we're so used to saying
yes
to get here but we really have to say no
to all the crap that doesn't serve us to
go to the next level so what habits do
you do out of a hypnotic rhythm
that you really have to say no to you
have to let go you have to not have them
as a part of your life and when you
throw them away that's when you get to
adopt new habits in your life
there's also things that are a part of
your so-called priorities
i really want you to analyze the
priorities you have in your life if
there if priorities are one to five
sometimes we have things in the five out
of five but they don't serve us they
don't serve god they don't serve your
bigger future they serve other people's
needs they serve the old version of you
they serve the dreams you used to have
when you were younger
you're gonna have to let them go
also your goals here's a crazy one
you're gonna have to let go of some
goals you're like oh dean you had me up
till this point you're gonna have to let
go of some goals
that don't
serve this new version of you i look
back at goals i had two years ago and
three years ago and i'm almost
embarrassed on some of them because i'm
always growing as a human if you're not
growing if you're not climbing you're
sliding so i'm always obsessing on
growing my soul growing my thoughts
growing my consciousness growing my
income growing my companies i go to
masterminds obsessively i do live events
obsessively i read obsessively so
when i look back at some goals sometimes
they stick and you have to you feel like
you have to accomplish them because i
put it down i got to make it happen i
look and i'm like no that doesn't serve
the man i want to be the husband i want
to be the father i want to be the leader
i want to be the impact i want to make
so i looked at some goals that are
lingering and i'm like they're actually
holding me back i have to throw them
away sometimes the best way to complete
a project is to quit it so what do you
have to quit today what do you have to
say no to what do you have to let go in
order to reach that next level of life
tap into the best
version of you listen we're always
talking about what we could gain i love
it i got to gain my dream house again it
didn't come overnight it didn't come by
accident it came because i changed my
habits it came because i learned to go
upstream and anchor in
the habits for success and that's why i
love every single week sharing with you
the subtle ways in less than 10 minutes
that you can anchor in new habits for
success today simply this we know if we
gain more we get more but the only way
you get more is to decide what you have
to let go of what you have to say no to
what do you have to push away take the
time this week and decide what goes in
the garbage so you can excel to that
next level of life rule number three
dream big with mel robbins i want to
teach you
how to train yourself to dream
big
it's actually a skill and dreaming big
is something that we used to do as kids
right it was so easy as kids to sit in
class because you were bored with you
know whatever it was that your teacher
was doing and you started to daydream
and as adults we tend to lose that
ability so the dream book is going to be
your companion to this program and
here's my philosophy about training
yourself to dream big again as an adult
in the dream book one of the things that
you're going to be doing as a daily
practice is you're going to do something
that i do in
my book and that is every time i crack
this open because i keep my notes in
here is i write down the five things
that i dream about
so i've written down okay i'm super
super embarrassed that i've written this
down so i'm gonna tell you what my five
are and you can see you probably can't
see how red i'm turning because i have
so much makeup on because i was on in
television today
and in television they put a lot of
makeup on you and digital they normally
look like but this is why we all need to
learn to dream big and to dream
authentically because when you talk
about it you immediately shrink because
we're trained not to have these
aspirations so the first thing that i
wrote down is i want to be the number
one talk show in the united states you
know what's so fascinating is i used to
dream of just actually being where i am
and now that i've achieved that i have a
dream that's even bigger and what does
it mean
and why is this dream important to me
and this is part of what you're going to
learn in the workbook but i'll tell you
why this dream is important to me
because if we are number one
it means that the work that we're doing
that i care so deeply about which is
helping people heal their minds and heal
their relationships and to live
a more positive
happy mentally well life that we're
reaching more people that's what that
means and that's why i want it i wrote
down number one new york times
bestseller i have for years said i don't
give a [ __ ] about it but i actually do i
guess
and i think it's because
it would be really nice
to have the powers that be
actually acknowledge the impact that
we're making do i need it to keep going
forward no
of course not and i will keep going
forward i want to make the time 100 list
for mental health and for the work that
we're doing and the reason why is
because as much as i like being
an entrepreneur that does things in a
very innovative way
that kind of public recognition
brings with it resources and partners
that would allow you to make an even
bigger impact and so when i think about
that kind of recognition
it challenges me to dream so much bigger
than i'm dreaming right now about the
impact that i want to make in mental
health the fourth one this is not my
dream right now but i wrote this down
three days ago and that is to be the
happiest i've ever been living in
vermont
the reason why i wrote that down at the
time is because
my son is going to go to high school in
vermont and we are grappling with a move
and i had a mental breakdown when we
started looking at houses there thinking
i couldn't live here
one of the interesting things about
dreaming is your dreams will change i
love the daily practice of writing in
your dream book the five things you're
dreaming about because you'll notice
that there are things that show up
consistently for you and that's a sign
that it's important to pay attention to
it it's important to walk toward it and
by writing i dream that i'd be the
happiest i'd ever be in vermont i was
doing the work of trying to shift my
attitude about how i was feeling about a
move when i'm not
that excited about it right now the
fifth one is i want to build a summer
house i grew up on lake michigan i've
spent the last 30 years
not on the water i dreamed to be
successful enough that someday in the
next decade i will have the money to buy
a fantastic piece of property on the
ocean and i will build an awesome house
that is a gathering place for our family
and hopefully that will not include
grandchildren in the next decade in the
dream book you're every single day going
to write the five things down that
you're dreaming about and it's okay that
they change because over the course of
this month i just want to teach you
how to give yourself permission to dream
and i think it's also important that you
saw how embarrassed i got when i had to
read the things that i wrote down to you
because i immediately
felt oh god are you going to judge me oh
gosh am i being a hypocrite oh god what
if i don't achieve these things who am i
to say these how am i going to do this
all that stuff rushed up for me and i'm
i'm the one teaching you how to do this
and it's important for you to see that
because all those feelings are normal
that are going to come up but they're
what's currently stopping you from doing
the work
to
live the next
best decade of your life and to pursue
the things that you dream about
it starts with training yourself
to give yourself permission to dream
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four venture into the
unknown with brendan burchard hey my
friend it's brendan and in this episode
what i want to talk with you about
is the price of change
you know we all go to change our lives
and we all want to improve our lives
whether you want to improve your health
or your relationships your work your
lifestyle you know
that sometimes
it's difficult and you back off of it
you back down from change because it's
scary i mean do you know anyone who
needs to change their life and you keep
telling them change change change but
they don't
why
or have you ever set a big goal at the
beginning of the year and you knew
you really wanted to achieve it
but you found yourself a couple months
later not doing it
well the reason is is because
psychologically
you were unwilling to face
the price of change it's kind of like
the way i think about it um
it's like admission gates like how you
know how you go into amusement park or
or a circus or to disneyland you kind of
have to pay
to go through the turnstile to enter and
enjoy the ride well change is like that
too most people bounce up against those
turnstiles though and they go this is i
don't like it it's uncomfortable to me
and they leave the park and they never
get to experience the beauty and the
wonder and the fun
on the other side they say ah it's not
worth it and they walk away from their
goals and their dreams and their hopes
because they just thought it wasn't
worth it or it was too hard so
what are you going to have to face
what are you really going to have to
allow yourself to pay for the price of
change well i think there's three
costs to change anytime you want to
change your life you're gonna be faced
with these three things they're the
price of admission to a better life and
once you realize that these are the
price
of change you can consciously choose
will is it worth it to me or not because
most people they're not consciously
choosing it they just get scared and run
so instead i want you to realize there
is a cost to change
are you up for it or not
here's the three costs to change that
first price of admission to get to the
other side of change is
uncertainty
you know when you go to change your life
you don't know how it's going to turn
out you start the new diet is it going
to work is it not you don't know
you're going to change your career or
quit your job are you going to get a
better job you don't know
you're going to leave that bad
relationship to find someone who really
loves you cares for you treats you well
are you going to find somebody better
you don't know
and that terrifies people
uncertainty is so scary because we might
lose something we like what if i lose
the job and it was okay or lose the
person she was not so bad or i lose that
opportunity
and it's scary to people but that's what
your mind has to be willing to wrap
around deal with your mind has to be
able to say to change your mind has to
go i am cool with the fact i'm not going
to know what the heck is going on i'm
going to go for it anyway
i'm going to enter that dark cave i
don't know if i'm going to be eaten
alive i don't know if it's going to turn
out bad but i'm going to go in i'm going
to trust and believe in my ability to
figure things out i don't know how it's
going to go but i know i'm going to show
up as the best of who i am to deal with
that change your mind must be allowing
and saying i'm going to let go of
everything i think i know
i'm going to let go of everything i want
it to go like i'm going to let go of my
need for permission i'm going to let go
of my need for perfection and i'm just
gonna try
and when you can get to that point
when you can say you know what i'm cool
with the fact i'm not gonna know what
the heck is going on on because i
haven't done it before i'm gonna try
even though i don't know how it's going
to turn out
if you can get over that that's that
first sort of step
into making longer term change for your
life see i'm okay with it i never know
how things are going to go as many of
you know i shoot this whole youtube show
this this thing called the charge life
my podcast i do it
extemporaneous i don't know exactly how
it's gonna go i usually know the topic i
know maybe one or two points in my head
and i just go
but my mind when i first did that it was
terrified so i said no no i need
certainty i need certainty
i need notes i need a script i i need to
know exactly how it's going to go and i
thought you know what that's not the
charge life the charge life is good with
spontaneity the charge life is good with
being in the moment the charge life
actually loves and draws energy and
power and vibrancy from
flow from being in the moment and
dancing with the moment versus having
everything needed to be script in your
life so have you not changed because
your mind is saying i need everything to
be perfect and scripted out i need to
know all the exact steps in the future
if your mind is telling you that i
guarantee
you're not progressing
growing
or achieving
at the rate that you could
you got to let go of certainty in your
life and be willing to venture into the
unknown and walk into it being okay that
you'll be vulnerable being okay that
you'll be scared being okay you're gonna
have nights where you're laying awake
going i don't know i don't know
and that's okay because you know what
you'll figure
it out
if i can tell you one belief that's
given me more confidence than anything
in my entire life it's like you know
what i know that i'm kind of a bumbling
fool
but i believe in my ability to figure
things out
put me in the mix put me in the game
coach i can do it i'd it will be a hot
mess for maybe a quarter but by second
quarter i'll get it i'll figure it out
put me in the game i will figure it out
i trust in that and that's why i've been
able to change my life so significantly
and grow so quickly beyond sometimes my
peers
because i'm willing to venture into the
unknown and they are not
and it is those who venture into the
unknown who are the adventurers the
pioneers the explorers those who move
the needle of change in the history of
the world so allow yourself not to know
and go
the second big price to change that a
lot of people avoid or run away from but
it's always going to be there is when
you bumble into something like that
guess what
the price to change
is other people might not understand
meaning
judgment
meaning rejection people might make fun
of you when you go to change your life
they might say who do you think you are
why do you want that well that's dumb
why are you doing that you're so stupid
why can't you just be happy
you're gonna get people saying that
there's a social
um fear
of change as well
because they would rather have you
conform to their little conception of
you see people draw a little conceptual
cage around who you are and they say
well this is who that person is they
think they know you they don't know you
and you know what they also don't know
they don't know tomorrow and they don't
know where you want to go they don't
know exactly what you are capable of
because they're trying to gauge it based
on their certainty
coming from the past
but who you are
is not
tethered to the past you and i can both
wake up tomorrow and claim what i call
my book life school and ticket a second
chance
you get to wake up tomorrow take a new
breath in decide
what am i going to show the world today
what am i going to do today how
disciplined am i going to be today what
energy am i going to arrive to the world
with and choose today what's my attitude
going to be what are my habits going to
be today what am i going to really go
after with thunder and power today you
get to choose that every day that's a
second chance every single day that's
the beauty of the world tomorrow is
always a blank slate tomorrow you get to
begin anew it takes guts and most people
don't have the guts because they're
scared of the rejection that could come
your spouse makes fun of you
and the people at work go what are you
crazy that's stupid
the kids in the play yard point and
tease and ridicule and abuse and be
but you know at the end of the day
it's your life
and you gotta decide what it stands for
are you gonna live your life based on
the the the noise of the crowds and the
masses telling you what to do
or living their life
or going to live your life are you going
to put your dreams on hold just because
some person who doesn't even know you or
what your capabilities are judged you
once look the reality is most people got
your back and it's not my opinion
it's reality
there all of us assume oh there's all
this judgment all these people are out
to get me look you need to stop
believing people don't support you and
want you to achieve and grow i used to
believe that i thought well
you know the people around me they'll
support me until i get above them right
no one wants you to be above them but
you know what above that's a bs
definition that's their meaning
definition not yours you're just growing
into your full potential don't apologize
for that don't hold back from that just
because somebody might not like it that
doesn't make any sense whatsoever
your job is to live that fullest
expression of who you know you can be
to do that confidently to live in that
freedom of flow of being spontaneous and
alive
regardless of what other people think
it's so easy to go well i better not
tell my dream because they'll think i'm
small
but if you don't tell your dream
your mind doesn't believe it if you
don't tell your dream the supporters who
would like the idea can't get your back
you don't tell your dream people can't
believe in you buy from you follow you
get on board with you look in silence is
suffering if you're not expressing who
you are and what you want in life that's
not personal freedom that's personal
caging of your soul and you're doing
that not anyone else it's easy to blame
everyone else well they judged me so i
stopped
no
they will always judge you you stopping
or starting that's on you buddy and we
got to accept that in our life that's
personal accountability going it's on me
no matter what the world says because
you know what you know when you're going
to get the believers you know you're
going to get them with momentum you know
when you're going to have more
motivation
with more momentum as you get going as
you start succeeding as you start
committing as they start to see wow
she's really interested in this wow
she's really doing while she's really
going going while she's really
succeeding more of them will clap at the
beginning they're all like weird and
then as you get going they're clapping
for you so don't forget that and don't
also forget that guess what
the bigger you grow to yep the more
people will judge you it's not like you
get success one day and everybody loves
you you know or you get millions of look
i got millions of students out there who
graduated my videos my online courses
who've read my books and we still get
people going well brandon you're an
idiot
millions of students if i bring in
you're an idiot or i do my videos and
they go well this is stupid you're just
you know
why don't you just stop doing these
videos your hair sucks i hate your shirt
you know it's like i don't care i don't
i'm not going to pause my mission
simply because there's some mean people
out there who are uninformed or in a bad
mood
you must not stop your march
out of a fear of rejection or judgment
because it never goes away what needs to
come back into your life is the
confidence you're gonna do it anyway
to go
and that's the price of change the price
of changes some people won't like it
but on the other side
that's your dream
so go
the last big price big cost of change
last huge one and most people don't like
it is that guess what to change to
progress it's going to bring struggle
struggle hardship
difficulty
that's part of the process
one
you gotta deal with the unknown that's
scary because you're not in the game
just like even thinking about scary
because it's the unknown
two
judgment rejection possibility and three
i i uh
this is gonna be hard
i'm not it's gonna be uncomfortable not
just uncertain it's gonna it's it's
gonna be difficult i'm gonna have to
stay up late nights to work on my dream
i'm gonna have to you know give up some
things i like doing with my family or my
friends sometimes so i can focus a
little bit more i like reading those
trashy magazines but i'm not adding
value they're comfortable for you i'm
gonna put them aside i'm gonna struggle
with the discipline
to stay focused
i'm going to struggle not knowing what
i'm doing looking silly i'm going to
struggle being absolutely a hot mess as
i begin this it's going to be hard it's
going to be a lot of late nights it's
going to be you know times are going
gonna try your soul your mind your body
and thank god
it's not easy
thank god it's not easy because you know
what it's only in the tough stuff that
your real character is exposed and
forged it's only in the difficulties
that the path becomes meaningful and
worthwhile if everything were easy none
of us would grow if everything were easy
none of us would learn if everything was
easy none of us would ever feel alive
it's in that struggle in the fight in
the challenge that we find real growth
that we find the charge like rule number
five get laser focused with jay shetty
how often do you get distracted research
shows that we're distracted every 40
seconds when we're sitting in front of a
computer or we're on our phones we spend
over 47 percent of our time when we're
browsing the internet or on our mobile
phones procrastinating and we check our
phones around 86 times per day put your
hand up if you check it more than that
so it's no surprise that we all face
distraction we all experience
distraction we're all plagued by
distraction but often we think that the
opposite of distraction is focus we
think that we need to become more
focused we think that if we're focused
we'll feel less distracted we feel that
if we're able to draw our energy in a
certain direction and force ourselves to
absorb in an activity then we won't be
as distracted but this is just not true
the opposite of distraction is actually
not focus the opposite of distraction is
wait for it attraction let me explain
what i mean when we're attracted to
something we're completely fixated we're
completely absorbed we're almost
addicted and obsessed to that visual
that song think of a time when you saw
someone that you found attractive i'm
guessing you couldn't take your eyes off
them think of a time when you heard a
song and you had it on repeat all
throughout the day no matter if there
was drilling outdoors there was a
building being demolished nothing could
distract you from the sound of that
voice and that beat i know you can hear
it in your head right now
[Music]
what we really need to do is increase
our attraction when we are attracted to
something we're naturally focused we're
naturally able to be present we're
naturally able to bring our attention
and our energy to that task that project
that person when we're distracted and
don't have that attraction we're
naturally all over the place we end up
feeling lost confused and end up
procrastinating as you can see we are
procrastinating and distracting others
so now i know what you're thinking how
do you get attracted to things that
you're not attracted to we all have
things in life that we love to do and we
all have things in life that we have to
do i'm sure you have a long list of
things that you have to do and you're
thinking jay i'm not attracted to any of
those things whether it's doing your
accounts whether it's taking the trash
out maybe it's even your job
it is my job so i've got a tip for you a
little trick a little insight that will
make your mind understand and believe
that it's attracted to something let's
take the example of your job it's
something that you have to do it's
something that you may not be attracted
to when you ask yourself why do i go to
my job maybe the answer is it pays my
bills maybe the answer is it allows me
to take care of my family maybe you
studied for years and feel that your job
at least engages you for that whichever
one your answer is that starts providing
some value to why you do that activity
when you know that you recognize that
you are attracted to be there because it
serves a particular purpose you start
becoming attracted because whenever your
mind says to you i'm bored i'm
distracted i'm unfocused you say no i'm
here because it puts food on the table
i'm here because it pays my bills and
takes care of my family i'm here because
i studied and worked hard for this
you're able to increase your attraction
to even the things you're totally
unfocused on now if you found yourself
distracted or unfocused for too long
that definitely can mean that you need
to find more meaningful fulfilling work
but no matter what you do no matter how
much you chase your passion and live
your purpose there will still be things
you have to do on a daily basis that you
don't find interesting and naturally you
will feel unfocused and distracted for
that ask yourself this question why am i
here why am i doing this and you'll find
the mind will start to become attracted
to that activity task or even that
person rule number six expect less with
alex hormozy this podcast is dedicated
to all of the uh younger entrepreneurs
out there so this is a little departure
from the normal business owner but i
think that you'll still find value in it
if you know any younger entrepreneurs or
you have uh you know teenagers or kids
or you know college you know college
aged people slash maybe even people in
their 20s 30s right who are getting into
business and so maybe you left your job
and you're getting into business now
whatever right this would apply to you
and
it's regarding expectations
and i think that expectations are
literally the thing that will destroy
your life uh or will make your life and
many of us uh i think many people in
general have you know figured out and
many world religions have figured this
out which is uh you know the secret to
happiness is uh
haves over wants
which is let's say you have
you know have
one thing and you want nothing
you will be infinitely happy the problem
is where you might have a million things
but you want two million things and you
will not be happy right and so you can
simply
change how happy you are by expecting
less
and so one of the things that i
specifically wanted to address today was
the expectations around education and
the reason this is a really meaningful
topic for me is that i've i think i've
talked to you about my neighbor um and
watching him go through the the crazy
expectations that he has as a young
person
has been really valuable for me because
i've also seen a lot of those
characteristics that he has in myself
just add zeros to it but it's still
fundamentally the same thing and that's
what's been uh
it's been meaningful for me and so
anyways
uh
i have tried to frame things uh so if
you are trying to learn things which is
going to be the first step to any kind
of entrepreneurial endeavor is i like to
liken everything to a bridge because i
think it's a simple visual so imagine
where you are on one side of you know
this
this valley right is where you are and
where you want to go is on the other
side of this big valley right and you
have a bridge that goes across the two
sides
now the problem is is that people will
buy
things they will buy courses they will
buy mentorships they'll buy workshops
they'll buy seminars they'll buy events
they'll buy whatever right
in an effort
on some level to get over this bridge
right of where they are to where they
want to go and it could be from zero to
a hundred thousand dollars a year it
could be from a million dollars a month
to two million dollars a month it could
be from a hundred million dollars a year
to a billion dollars a year whatever it
is there's a bridge right
and
along that bridge are bricks
and i like to liken um each skill as a
brick on the way to where you're trying
to go
and the problem with the expectations of
somebody who's trying to learn a skill
or achieve a goal is that they have a
binary outcome i either achieved it or i
did not i either am making a hundred
thousand dollars or i am not and the
problem is it can be incredibly
frustrating because if you have a binary
outcome
uh then it's very easy to get a zero out
of one right where
the reality is
most things are exist on a continuum and
so this is the difference between a
psychological binary and a and and the
biological continuum which is i'll give
you a couple of examples so it's not uh
uh are you diabetic or you're not
diabetic it's how diabetic are you right
it's not uh
are are you smart are you dumb but it's
how smart are you right and so we like
to psychologically bucket things into
yes nose because it's simpler for us but
it it it misses actual reality right
and this can be especially dangerous as
we're trying to acquire new skills and
so the reason i liken this and i think
it's so dangerous in education uh
because that's what we're doing right if
we're trying to educate ourselves we're
trying to acquire skills is that we
think as we're trying to get across this
bridge that let's say you buy a course
on copywriting right and so you're on
one side of the bridge you buy a course
on copywriting and then you still aren't
a millionaire
wow right
the problem is uh
you may have put another brick on your
bridge you may be closer
to where you were
to getting to the other side of the
bridge you just haven't achieved it yet
and so this is one of the issues that i
also see um just in general like it's so
funny because in the in the in the i'll
say quote guru world um you know people
will take on a coach that coach will
move them forward you know to a certain
degree and then they'll take another
coach and that coach will move them
forward to a certain degree and so forth
and so on and then the thing is is that
they're they're like
i'm working with so-and-so i used to
work with that person they suck right
but the problem and i used to do this
right like and this is why i think it's
so ridiculous um is that like if you
were looking at your schooling right and
you had a had a third grade math teacher
and then later you had a calculus
teacher
you wouldn't be like screw that third
grade you know uh math teacher the stuff
that i'm learning from this guy is so
much you know more advanced whatever
right
and i've had a lot of our clients say
that about their franchises that they
work with and things like that and i
just it it drives me nuts because it's
it's it's stupid you know it's for lack
of it's stupid because a lot of times
you need
you need step one to get to step two
right and you don't have to and p it's
because people have psychological issues
but like they they can't they can't say
i've learned from all of these people
right and it doesn't it doesn't decrease
your status to say i've learned from
many teachers look at all the richest
people in the world they say like i've
had multiple mentors i've had so many
people help me out over the years and i
think if you can shift that perspective
it will be incredibly valuable for you
but one of the other things that's so
poisonous about especially in the like
the quote make money world is that if we
if if everyone in the world viewed
college because i think about this a lot
i'm like why is it that
people will spend two hundred thousand
dollars four years of their lives
study you know
aztec literature of the 1700s and get to
the end and not in any way be upset
about the fact
that they're not making money when they
graduate they can't even get a job like
why is that
and the only reason that i can come up
with is that they didn't expect to right
and so that's it like that's the
difference is that people come in and
part of that is because the marketing
messaging and the sales and all that
kind of stuff so don't be wrong like the
reason that you know the big academic uh
powerhouse has been able to stay there
well one is because they got the
government to get on board and give away
free money so that's obviously one part
of it but the other part of it is that
when people are coming in they they
expect nothing
like nothing literally they're not
expecting anything they expect to get a
check mark next to the name that says
you have a diploma congratulations right
and so uh if
my my
my request of everyone
um and i've requested this of myself is
that when i go into trying to learn
something that i do not have give myself
a binary outcome of uh did this work or
did not work but instead give myself the
question
am i closer or further away from my goal
and i think that has been tremendously
helpful i've i've spent i mean recently
i i spent fifty thousand dollars on uh i
think eight hours with someone uh it was
different than uh the
the grant cardone one that i did um
that's that was four hours for 120 000
if you're curious um and honestly
i got enough value in the first hour
that i was like i don't know what i'm
gonna do with the next three calls um
with grant it was really good um but the
point is this you know with the other
one that i that i did
it was actually to have assistance on a
higher level project that i was working
on and about halfway through i realized
that um it was not a priority uh for me
and so i could either say this got me
you know i'm not gonna be like hey screw
this guy right or anything like that it
was just um for me if i can get the
perspective that something is not a
priority that is valuable in and of
itself and so does that take me closer
or further to my ultimate goal closer
and so why would i be satisfied and so
shifting uh our education expectations
to
is this another brick on the bridge to
where i'm trying to go
or
instead of excuse me instead of
am i at my destination or not and i
think that this is probably one of the
biggest things that you can do or like
that it's or it's been useful for me and
this is what i've tried to shift my
neighbor's perspective uh for himself on
which is
it's kind of alignment with that kind of
investor mindset which is
if i were to look over a five year time
horizon and i were to continue to
acquire skills like this would i and i
put more and more bricks on my bridge
by the end of that period
would i be better or worse off and
likely it'd be better but you will be
worse off if you keep trying to build a
new bridge right and that's why when you
jump from opportunity to opportunity a
lot of times you can never get to where
you're trying to go because you take two
steps of progress and say oh i'm not
there binary outcome therefore i will
start something else and it's only after
failing three four five six things then
on the seventh thing
you had enough acquired skills from your
first six failures that you were
actually able to make it all the way
across the bridge and that's what's kind
of interesting about this is that like
there are plenty of people who uh you
know have come to us and immediately
start making a lot of money right and
then they and then they're like oh my
god jim lunch is awesome and the thing
is is that like
i we don't honestly deserve all the
credit because
you probably like some of these people
may have gone through three four five
courses that they believe failed them
when in reality there may be 38 skill
sets that they need to create their
their business you know core skills and
they may have acquired 24 of them from
other people and we just happen to be
able to get them the last 14 that gets
them all the way across but because they
have a binary outcome expectation they
then attribute all the credit to us and
i don't think that's fair um
you know uh to themselves in terms of
their mental space but also to everyone
else that they've worked with right
and so
i think thinking about it this way has
been really helpful and especially and
this is again i mentioned the franchisor
one earlier but i'm gonna say it again
i i can't tell you the amount of
facilities specifically that worked with
the franchisor and then said you know
started working with us started making
more money and we're like i hate my
franchisor you got you know like screw
them blah blah blah but the reality is
that many times they wouldn't have even
survived long enough without the
fundamental bricks that had been laid by
the franchisor with their business model
there's so many fundamentals that they
may not even been aware of and mistakes
that they would have made that were
avoided because the franchisor got them
70 percent of the way across the bridge
right
and we just got them the last 30. right
and so um
another perspective on this as well is
that let's say you've got two people who
all have who both have all 38 bricks on
this bridge right on the on the path of
your opportunity vehicle you're trying
to pursue to get to the other side right
now let's say both of them have all both
all 38 bricks
but
with your learning style and their
teaching style you're only able to
accurate or you know absorb
25 of the first guys right it's kind of
the same thing right it's like for some
reason like you know i
maybe the first ones you worked with
taught you how to sell but like you
didn't absorb or wasn't real for you and
then later on in your life uh it was
able to be real for you and then you
attribute your success uh to the second
person when in reality the first person
helped you along the way and so um this
has just been really valuable uh for me
from a shift in perspective in my
overall happiness
but also just in thinking about outcomes
and what
what what do i believe is reasonable and
i think i've been i've been asking
myself this question much more
frequently which is do i believe my
expectations are reasonable and is there
a way that i can lower them and
there's there's difference between
lowering your expectations of the
performance you want of people i believe
you should be absolutely intolerant of
people who do not want to be world class
at something
or you should be intolerant of any lack
of effort
but if you can maintain
absolute intolerance to anything but
excellence but then also decrease your
expectations of the outcome
then that is going to be a winning
formula so
increase expectations on activity and
actions
decrease expectations on outcomes and i
think that that is a formula for
business success just as
uh
haves over wants is a
formula for happiness in life and rule
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is ship your
mindset with john assan hey i was just
on this new app called clubhouse and i
got so pissed off
because this one guy who's a very
well-known internet marketer makes
millions of dollars a year
was going on and on and on about mindset
and he didn't know what the
heck he was talking about as far as the
real understanding of mindset he was
telling people that we're listening
there's probably about 1500 people
listening you know you just have to have
a great attitude and just have to
overcome your limiting beliefs and
overcome your fears and and don't allow
the obstacles to hold you back persevere
be persistent
well if it was that freaking easy
everybody would just go oh okay i'll do
that but it's not that easy
let me explain what i mean to you so you
have a healthy understanding of you know
mindset and what what's going on in here
your brain
there's a part of your brain called the
left prefrontal cortex that chooses your
goals and you get excited and motivated
and share it with your friends and your
family and you're already thinking about
the car you're going to buy and the home
you're going to buy and the amount of
money you're going to make and how
you're going to live
well there's another few parts of your
brain
okay that may not be in concert or
coherence or flow
with this vision and goal you have even
though you're excited and you really
want them
let me go a little bit deeper
when somebody has a goal that is outside
of their current habitual way of
thinking and feeling and being
outside of their current way of thinking
feeling and being
fear centers in the brain uncertainty
centers in the brain doubt anxiety
stress centers circuits in the brain
actually activate
and release neurochemicals into your
body that causes you to feel stressed
worried fearful of failing being
embarrassed ashamed ridiculed or judged
now
that is your emotional center in your
brain not your logical thinking center
in your brain that is responsible for
setting goals
so if somebody tells you just get over
it you know
believe this instead of that
they're
ignorant meaning not knowing
the neural circuitry of your brain and
how this thing you know called a brain
this organism
okay
is wired
for safety and survival first is wired
to avoid any pain or discomfort so any
time that you want to set a goal
that is outside of your current comfort
zone your current habits
this part of your brain activates like a
like a fire truck okay or a fire bell
okay in a fire station going off off
off that this is out of your comfort
zone and simply saying well just
persevere
is ludicrous
now what can you do
let's take
your self-image that may be holding you
back if there is a disconnect between
what you want to achieve and your hidden
self-image which means or says in your
own mind i'm not good enough i'm not
smart enough i'm not worthy
you better know that the self-image that
you currently have is preventing you
from achieving the goal the identity and
the characteristic trait of the person
you need to be in order to achieve your
goals and there is going to be a battle
inside your head and i'll give you
solutions in just a second
if you have limiting beliefs like you're
not good enough not worthy enough you
don't have enough money knowledge skills
you're too young you're too old
neural patterns in your brain is what
beliefs are
and we have constructive ones
destructive ones empowering ones
disempowering ones positive and negative
neural patterns called beliefs
the key is to deactivate
the beliefs that disempower you and to
create a new belief that matches the
vision and goal you have
then we have the fears i talked about
i'm going to give you a couple
techniques
if you have a fear of
having a goal and failing
you're not going to take action because
as soon as that circuit turns on
for the failure circuit which is the
fear circuit
and guess what happens
all of the motivation that you had goes
out the window and you either fight
freeze or flee meaning running away
doing something else like procrastinate
instead of doing what you need to do so
if you have a fear of failure of your
success a fear of being embarrassed
ashamed ridiculed or judged
these are going to turn off your
motivational centers and activate your
fear centers so
i'm not going to leave you hanging
without a solution
first and foremost understand that you
and i
became conditioned because of our
parents our teachers television radio
our experiences what we heard what we
saw what meanings we gave things which
means that we became conditioned we
weren't born with any beliefs or fears
of self-image challenges
we developed them
and in neuroscience and neuropsychology
terms means
that we developed the patterns that got
reinforced to become the natural
easy way for us to be even though we may
not want it so
what if you wrote down a limiting belief
that you had
okay i'm not smart enough not good
enough not worthy i don't have the money
i don't have the time i don't have this
i'm too young i'm too old write out
whatever you want
and then what if
you just created a new language pattern
and reframed it and said in the past
i used to believe fill in the blank and
now i believe that i am smart enough i
am good enough i am worthy i can achieve
this i can't find the money i can
upgrade my knowledge i can't upgrade my
skills and i am excited and enthusiastic
to achieve the vision and goal of and
write in the blank now
if you wrote that out
and you repeated it and emotionalized it
and felt it as if you were a hollywood
actor or actress learning a new role you
would activate something called the
neuroplasticity switch in your brain
that would cause new neurons to connect
and if you reinforced it for the next
hundred days by reading it
emotionalizing it recording it and
listening to it
you would take a new pattern that you
wrote out and then you would impress it
through space repetition repetition okay
is what is required in order to
strengthen and reinforce a neural
pattern and practice is what makes
permanent let me repeat practicing a
paragraph or an affirmation of what you
want is what makes permanent what that
means is it makes the neural network
permanent and it replaces the old
pattern it takes 66 days to 365 days to
do this so don't do it for a week going
nothing's happening
66 days to 365 days that's for limiting
beliefs what if at the same time
right after you did that
you visualized and saw yourself
overcoming any of your limiting beliefs
your obstacles your challenges you saw
yourself winning you saw yourself
achieving the goals and dreams that you
have you saw yourself with more
self-confidence more certainty than ever
before and you felt it again as if you
were a hollywood actor actress getting
paid to pretend you're doing this role
now visualization is simulation and
again when you simulate
you create neural patterns that
reinforce and over a period of time they
become
dominant so if you think about what does
a hollywood actor or actress do to learn
their role they practice it over and
over and over again they feel it they
bring in all of their senses and then
they become the role and hopefully they
win an academy award
you have to break the habit of being
your current self and create the
character the identity the story and the
beliefs of the person capable of
achieving every one of your business
goals that's two number three is fears
fear is not your enemy
fear is nothing more than an automatic
circuit in the brain to warn you that
something
might harm you physically emotionally
spiritually financially etc
and your job is to pay attention to the
fear signal
and then
to do it
anyway as long as it's safe so in order
to deactivate
the fear circuit
how about taking six deep breaths
in through your nose slowly
slowly
slowly
and then breathe out through your mouth
as if you're breathing out through a
straw
slowly
six times
we can see
in brain scan images
that six breaths slowly in and slowly
out
releases eliminates
deactivates
the fear or stress center otherwise
known as the parasympathetic nervous
system and it activates the i'm sorry it
deactivates the sympathetic nervous
system and it activates the
parasympathetic nervous system the
parasympathetic nervous system is part
of your calm
to be able to respond system versus your
stress reactive system
and so
you have a brain you're not your brain
your brain has a nervous system with
circuits that turn on and off what about
practicing managing the emotional
circuit
possible yes and if you did inner size
number one which is what i just showed
you take six com the circuits
and then you did inner size number two
which is called ayah awareness intention
action and so in a calm relaxed state
you now become aware of your negative
thoughts negative emotions negative
feelings sensations or behaviors
that are preventing you from achieving
your goal that are causing you to be
stuck or frozen or in a state of fear
and now you set one intention for what
you're going to do to take inspired
action and then you take one
simple step towards the goal vision and
dream that you have
the biggest difference between you
and the people who you look up to
are that they started
and you're still thinking about it
it's one of the most frustrating things
in helping entrepreneurs
that i deal with on a day-to-day basis
is that seeing so much potential in
people seeing so much heart and love and
care it's like you you could be serving
so much and helping so much and having
such a big impact
and and
we're stuck
we're stuck
and this was me too i was stuck it took
me forever to get started and
i thought i had to have the the perfect
cameraman my first video if you go back
and watch my channel i had my friend
come and film it and record it for me
because i was worried about it not being
perfect enough that i didn't know the
gear and didn't know the microphone and
the lighting and the setup and i i
memorized the script because i didn't
want to say the wrong words i had to be
perfect uh most of my early videos were
still mostly voice over because i could
write a script and have it perfect and
just have b-roll and it wouldn't be me
on camera afraid of making mistakes and
saying the wrong things and messing up
and that's one of the main reasons why
it took me so long to grow
you know if you look at my journey of
making
what for five years seven thousand
subscribers something like that
it was i was stuck i was i was
i was too afraid to do the next thing i
was too afraid to get in the race i was
making content at least that was one
decent thing for whatever reason i stay
consistent on on doing stuff but i was
afraid to take the next step the big
step to go off and do it and
a lot of you
are already way better than than i was
when i started
and when i'm on interviews and i'm i'm
doing events and presentations and i see
the audience and i see who's there and i
see the skill and the in the heart just
the this is the thing that kills me the
most it's like the heart it's like you
want you've got such a good heart you
want to do so much
and then there's just no action there's
no momentum because of the fear
if you could make one change
this year
that would really move the needle it
would be to stop judging yourself for
the content that you're making or the
product you're putting out or the
service and just expect it to suck and
keep going so when people ask me
should i
should i do this business or this
business should i do that business or
this one's like well i don't know you
know like at the end of the day it's
gonna be what you love doing all of them
could work
every business model can work and has
worked it's what's going to be the right
one for you and you won't know until
you get out there and start doing it
right it's like how do you know what
your favorite food is until you get out
there and do it how do you know if you
like
coffee or not you know
you have to go off and you take a sip
and then you find out you can't think
your way through this so you can't think
your way you can have some planning but
the planning won't save you at the end
of the day you have to go off and just
do something about it and in the doing
you'll figure out
what makes you come alive and keep going
so
let's make it practical it'll give us
give you some steps for how to actually
get in the race and start taking some
action
step one
understand
or at least tell yourself that great
ideas flow through you
great ideas flow through you that
because you came up with the idea that
it's a good idea stop judging and stop
telling yourself you suck stop telling
yourself someone like you can't do it
that great ideas flow through you this
is a good idea you need to go do
something about it right even just
telling yourself that shortcuts the fear
because all of the reasons in your head
for why you can't do it is really just
fear if you think about making content
and you're worried about the microphone
and the camera and the
gear and all that that's just fear
talking it's just you're afraid that it
won't be good and so you're trying to
cover your bases and we come up with all
these logical reasons why we can't do it
but really just fear talking so
cut through the fear by telling yourself
that
great ideas flow through you
that you don't want to be sitting here
three years later
still stuck in the same spot
right what's the difference well how
much action you took over those three
years and most of us
are are stuck in inaction
because we're paralyzed by fear and
we've come up with rational reasons why
we can't do the thing so one great idea
is flow through you trust them and do
something about them two apply what i
call the two percent difference and so
most of the time what's the first thing
we do when we come with an idea
when you come up with an id you think
it's a great idea you're gonna start a
channel you're gonna write a book you're
gonna create this product service
company whatever you come up with a
great idea
the first thing we do is usually
planning right plan plan plan i need to
plan here's what my perfect world looks
like i'm going to plan all the way out
and what ends up happening is you spend
your best energy planning the first step
in my opinion should not be planning the
first step should be some kind of
imperfect action because what ends up
happening is you get all this energy and
motivation and you feel like you're
unstoppable and you can do it this is
such a good idea
and then you start spending your time
planning and researching what does that
happen is you wake up the next day and
the next day and
your energy and your belief starts to
drop to go what was i thinking i can't
do that who am i to do that the doubts
and insecurities and the fears all start
to pop in and so you you stop
and nothing ends up happening besides a
list of ideas and you're planning and
research but that doesn't that doesn't
get you paid that doesn't get the
service out there doesn't actually help
anybody and so
planning is important it just shouldn't
be the first step the first step should
be some kind of imperfect action just
start doing something anything you you
want to make a youtube channel great
pull out your phone and make a video
what do you see on the video it doesn't
matter just speak from the heart like
hey
i want to start a youtube channel i've
been thinking about doing this for
a bunch of years and i've always been
too afraid and
now i've decided that i'm going to go
off and do it and i don't know what i'm
going to talk about i'm going to do my
best and hopefully you'll support me all
right see you soon
post there's your video was it great no
but it's everything because you you
started doing something
you think about a fitness plan that
people are going on
what do people normally do on a fitness
plan well you you're researching all do
i do crossfit do i do weights do i do
cardio or do i do zumba do i do salsa
dancing and you're so caught up we all
get this we all get so caught up in what
the perfect plan is that we never
actually do anything where the the best
thing you can do is go and do ten
push-ups right now
or five or two however many you can do
are those two push-ups going to make any
difference
for the long-term health no i mean no
you're not building muscle from two push
ups obviously but
the mo the act of momentum is the thing
that matters because in doing the two
push-ups maybe tomorrow you do four the
next day you do six next thing you do
eight and you're starting to build the
habit of somebody who does push-ups that
then can lead you to do more research to
find out oh i was doing the push-ups all
wrong
here's a better way to do it or i should
be doing this instead you'll learn as
you go and the research in a plan is
important it just can't be the first
step
so step one again is expect that great
ideas flow through you that that idea
that came to you is good is worthy you
should do it you should at least try it
step number two is two percent
difference what that means is
don't plan to get the hundred percent
for focus on the first two percent most
of us will plan to figure out what the
100 looks like you won't know what's the
first two percent you can take action on
right now and just go do it and then
step three is just expect to suck at the
beginning
we expect we don't expect to be great at
the start but we expect to be good we
expect to be at least average at the
start of whatever we do we never think
it's going to be easy i mean some people
do i guess but for the most part you
don't think whatever you're getting into
is going to be easy but you don't expect
it to be as hard as it is and you don't
expect to be as bad as you are at the
thing and it doesn't mean that you're
bad as a human it just means that you're
bad at the skill
and so how do you get skills well by by
practicing by doing it by training right
and so you're gonna be way worse
than you thought you would be at the
beginning that's okay you just don't
have the skill yet so i go into any new
thing expecting to suck just completely
expect to suck expect it to be a total
failure
and if it's not then great
and every day you get up and you do it
again you'll be a little bit better and
you'll suck a little bit less because
you're developing the skills you can get
really really good at something if you
have passion energy and you're pouring
time into actually improving at it where
most people
will just make one thing
see how much it sucks and then never go
back to it so just expect it to be
terrible at the beginning
don't worry so much about how much of a
failure that first one was and then you
keep going keep you make another one
tomorrow and another one tomorrow
another tomorrow and you will get better
if you follow that process this is this
is how you actually start becoming the
person who you want to be you start
getting the results and the impact that
you want to have
you've got the heart and the talent and
the the abilities
and the care
the difference is just there's no
momentum or there's not enough momentum
for what you're capable of and so if you
follow those three steps
right great ideas flow through you
believe it follow the two percent
difference instead of planning research
and do something you need action and
then three expect to suck and keep going
you get that momentum you need start
changing your life
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see my amazing one-on-one
interview with andre norman check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe see
you there if you are comfortable
someplace you're probably in the wrong
place
comfortable
is bad
because it leads to contentment you're
not trying there's no effort whenever
you stop failing
you're done